ich habe mich eben wirklich tot gelacht
und zwar fragt selina würdest du lieber
eine ziege fliegt nur niemand weiß es
oder doch keine ziege [ __ ] aber jeder
denkt ist hey was geht ab jetzt
willkommen beim neuen video immer wieder
auf einem kanal und so und ja ich habe
irgendwie total bock auf video und ich
muss mir noch was mitteilen deswegen
habe ich mir gedacht komm du beantwortet
heute einfach mal so ein paar fragen ihr
seid gehabt irgendwie total komplett
ausgerastet und ich habe mega viele
fragen bekommen zum glück habe ich jetzt
nicht mehr auf install und postet das
ihr mir auch noch fragen stellen sollte
weil das wäre dann irgendwie unnötig
gewesen
auf jeden fall ja ich habe jetzt hier
gedacht kommen beantwortet einfach mal
so 10 und dann wollte ich euch noch wird
sagen und bürger von wally reckmann
ich habe noch überhaupt keine ahnung
welche jetzt nehmen ich habe dir vorher
noch gar nicht gelesen
super leben weil es einfach mal eine von
den ersten und zwar wie würdest du
reagieren wenn du erfährt dass deine
freundin ins ausland ziehen würde
was wäre scheiße dann werde ich bestimmt
ziehen also dann würde ich mit ziehen
ganz einfach doch kommt darauf an
also wenn ich noch schule machen muss
dass wir auf jeden fall mega scheiße
aber zum glück ist es nicht so immer
immer vom realen ausgehen wie haben
deine freunde reagiert also mit youtube
angefangen hast ich kriege wirklich pro
tag
andauernd nachrichten da sagen welche
jordan ist voll cool dass du dir das
traust ich will mir das niemals trauen
warum bitte nicht mein klar ist es ganz
normal am anfang dann sein geld was das
denn oder so aber sobald ihr ein
bisschen erfolg hat sagen wir mal 500
abonnenten ok 500 abonnenten ist schon
mein weg dazu aber 1.000 abonnenten hält
wirklich jeder die fresse von daher
macht einfach und scheiß egal was die
anderen sagen fertig ich habe mich eben
wirklich tot gelacht und zwar fragt
selina würdest du lieber eine ziege fit
nur niemand weiß es oder doch keine
zicken aber jeder denkt ist richtig
geile frage ich glaube die leute die
hier bekommen habt auch wenn das schwer
zu beantworten ist aber ich denke ich
bin dann schon eher sagen ich würde
nie im leben auf die idee kommt eine
ziege ihr wisst schon
dann soll es halt jeder denken aber auf
jeden fall keine frage
ja die frage wollte ich immer schon
waren wurden uns vorab fragt da via was
hältst du von mobbing also in der
sechsten klasse oder so sage ich mal da
sind ist man noch nicht so weit dass man
sich dann weiter darüber gedanken macht
aber jetzt scheck die leute einfach
nicht die jetzt noch irgendwelche
personen morgen oder so wenn man schon
in einem etwas erwachsenenalter ist weil
keine ahnung ich finde es einfach mega
scheiße wenn es jetzt auch bis vor allem
unberechtigt ist wenn sie es wegen dem
aussehen ist oder weil die person
irgendwas nicht kann oder so ist das
total behindert wenn es jetzt wegen
irgendwas ist wo die person vielleicht
auch selber daran schuld ist weil sie
vielleicht andere personen mit
reingezogen hat oder so kann ich es
vielleicht ab und zu mal ein bisschen
nachvollziehen aber trotzdem wenn das
jetzt wirklich ohne einen grund zu haben
weil die personen weiß ich nicht anders
aussieht oder so richtig behindert als
die letzte die sowas machen ist einfach
so so nächste frage
hier war das ekligste was sie gegessen
hast stand degradieren wohl keine ahnung
auf jeden fall habe ich mal vor
eineinhalb jahren oder so in einem video
zahnpasta gegessen und das war ich mega
ekelig mir war danach bestimmt drei
stunden schlecht und schaut mal kurz
rein ich glaube ich finde dass noch mehr
ich sag das mal kurz
ja wenn ich gerade durchs grüne ganz
viel haben die frage gestellt und zwar
wie würdest du dich entscheiden oder was
würdest du machen deine freundin oder
youtube kann ich erst mal vorweg sagen
klar würde ich mich für meine freundin
entscheiden auch wenn youtube
richtigkeit abgeht zurzeit erst macht
mir mega spaß ist auch mein liebstes
hobby sag ich mal
aber ist ja klar dass ich mich dann doch
für meine freunde entscheide denke ich
mal sollte jedem fall auch verständlich
vorkommen voll geil jetzt kommt grad
sonne so schön rein
das heißt letztlich war sie das bloß
letzte frage willst du auch mal die eine
million abonnenten haben
quatsch natürlich nicht wer will das
denn schon mehr spaß
ich würde mich zwar schon mega 300.000
freuen das ist gar nicht mal mehr so
unrealistisch auch wenn es doch langer
weg sein könnte aber wenn sich das so
krass entwickelt wie gerade dann geht es
glaube ich ziemlich schnell auf jeden
fall vegas was gerade so abgeht
da kommt so viele hat es kommen so viele
dazu einfach noch mal dafür krasses
dankeschön und er dann hier noch die
frage zum überleiten
gehst du zum video na ja ich bin was wir
jetzt auf jeden fall noch sagen wollte
ich freitag samstag sonntag und montag
nach köln
da bin ich die ersten beiden tage auf
dem video day und die zwei tage danach
noch auf media kraft sommercamp das wird
schon auch mega geil auf jeden fall bin
ich da in köln
ich versuche jeden tag so viel zu finden
wie möglich und schneiders an abends
zusammen das heißt es kommen vier videos
hintereinander einmal am freitagabend
samstag am sonntagabend und montagabend
wenn das nur hin und sollte wie es
geplant haben auf jeden fall check time
abends schön meint channel ob neues
video da ist schaut euch dann würde ich
mich freuen wenn ihr das ja kräftig
verfolgt ansonsten was es mit diesem
video fasst euch ein bisschen gefallen
habt gebt doch einfach mal daumen nach
oben wenn ihr auch wirklich dabei seid
bei den vier videos die folgen
auf jeden fall instagram alles und in
der video beschreibung hier auf der
linken seite geht es weiter mit meinem
letzten video das war dinge die jungs
ein mädchen ich verstehen und hier auf
der anderen seite ja da kommt noch mal
erste fragen beantworten wie du rein ich
habe viele versprecher heute
und ja bis freitag dann hoffentlich x
und 3